E OPENING
FACE-OFF AGAINST LOGAN COUTURE
US.
HE SPENT
GOALS SO YOU TO BE AWARE THE TH
END OF THE SHIFT.
HIM.
IT'S EVERYTHING ELSE THAT HE
DOES AS WELL.STYLE.
THEY REALLY STARTED IT LAST
YEAR AND THEYD
ON.
YOU CAN SEE SO MANY NOW IN THE
GREGOR WAS SPEED THROUGH SENATE
GETS TO THE PANTHER
35 SECONDS LEFT AND FINALLY THE
THE PANTHER LINE.
THE ARROW TRACKS IT  EARLY IN
THE SECOND PERIOD.
AND THE SHARKS AGAIN HA.
THEY HAVE AN ODD MAN RUSH.
CARLSON HELPING WITH THORTON.
IT WAS UP HIGH
DIVING  IN
SHARP DEFENSE AND ALEKSANDER
BARKOV WITH THAT BIG BODY UNABL
YOU'RE GOING TO SEE SOME
IS STOLEN.
CLEARLY HE IS
26 ASSISTS.
17 DIFFERENT THAT PLAYERS TOOK
MASON GETS THE
THEY GET THAT PUCK POSSESSIO
AND YOU COULD NOT DRAW IT UP IT
CLASSIC SHOULDER TO SHOULDER.
FRESH LEGS ON THE ICE.